you
Jim O'Toole thank you very much. I will now hold a roll call vote.
Brooks, please call the roll.
Ms. Darlene Hammond.
Aye.
Ms. Cabello.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Ms. Lewis.
Ms. McQuillan.
Aye.
Ms. Olken.
Yes.
Ms. Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Aye.
Ms. Patilabraunsen.
Yes.
Ms. Porter.
Aye.
Ms. Rodriguez.
Yes.
Mr. Yoshimoto-Towry.
The motion carries unanimously.
All right, thank you.
We're gonna move on now to item 12.
Item 12 is the State Annual Performance Report
for Part B of the Individuals with Disabilities
Education Act, covering program year 2021 to 2022.
The California Department of Education recommends
that we review and approve the executive summary
for the FFY 2021 APR for Part B of the IDEA,
covering program year 2021 to 22,
as prepared by the Special Education Division.
And the item will be presented by Heather Kalamis of the CDE.
Heather, please begin.
Good morning.
It's a pleasure to see you all present
the Special Education Division's FYI 2021 update
of our annual performance report.
In addition to hearing how the state of California
is progressing towards our targets,
you will also hear how the Special Education Division
is working to improve our performance on the targets,
as well as the partnerships we have strengthened
both internally and externally to improve outcomes
for students with disabilities.
With that, we'll get started with a few slides
that will ground us in data in terms of who we're serving,
and remind you that we serve a student population
that is rich in diversity and rich in need across our state.
We will also then take a deeper dive
across our 17 federally mandated indicators,
and then finally we'll highlight the partnerships
and the work that's being done across the state,
and hear from our Multilingual Support Division
and our Early Education Division on joint efforts
across our division to support students
with disabilities as well.
What you see here are typical slides
just in terms of overall who we're serving
in the state of California.
Our total enrollment in this slide here
is reflective of students with disabilities
from birth to age 22.
As you can see, there's been a slight decrease
in total enrollment of students with disabilities
over the past two years.
Not different or similar to the overall
general education population decline in enrollment
in the state of California as well.
This next slide here just walks us through
the past 10 years of both population of K-12 students
and also the percentage of students with disabilities
in the state of California over the past 10 years.
As you can see here, while there's been a decrease
in overall enrollment, the percentage of students
with disabilities has grown, right?
So it's an interesting dynamic here
that obviously for us here in the state of California
continues to show the need for resources,
state investments, and statewide support for LEAs
and professional development for educators,
paraprofessionals, and administrators as well.
This is a number we will certainly keep our eyes on
to ensure that we have effective systems
and supports in place as well.
These slides here, similar to previous years,
there has not been much change from our last APR cycle.
The numbers have stayed consistently from year to year.
The only addition or sort of change was the,
there was about a 1% increase for both foster youth
and socioeconomically disadvantaged students
in terms of the local control funding formula as well.
But the numbers have stayed about the same
over the past two years.
In terms of the percentage of students with IEPs
in one or more of the LCFF student groups
for the previous year, again, stayed fairly consistent.
No large increases or decreases in this category as well.
In terms of over the past six months,
the special education division has been engaging
in strategic planning and priority setting,
which I hope the board can hear about soon
in the coming months.
The work of our division can be bucketed
into the following areas that you see here,
monitoring and target technical assistance,
data collection and reporting, effective dispute resolution,
inter-agency professional development,
fiscal management, and non-public schools.
As such, we have a very large division
and oversee a wide variety of activities
in terms of our general supervision.
But we, in terms of our strategic planning,
are developing priorities to ensure that we have aligned
and integrated data-driven governance
and accountability and support systems
that reflect the priorities of equity, diversity,
and inclusion, inclusive practices that are driven
by high-quality program, planned and documented
with high-quality IEPs, and also ensuring
that we have healthy and a well-trained workforce
to professional development systems
and recruitment efforts as well.
So more to come on the strategic planning.
But certainly this is also a piece
that is guiding our work moving forward as well.
In terms of our monitoring system,
the special education has a tiered monitoring system.
And the state of California has made investments
over the past two years to better align
both special education and general education systems.
For instance, the LCAP addendum,
the group parent participation.
There is a tremendous opportunity for deep engagement
at the SCA level, county office level,
SOPA level, and LEA level to improve outcomes
for students with disabilities.
We must ensure that our systems are designed
in a way that supports all learners
and reflects efforts across multiple areas
to reach our goal.
It's important to note that roughly 177 of LEAs
in differentiated assistance for students with disabilities
have already conducted a data analysis
and root cause analysis to address outcomes
for students with disabilities
through our special education SIM process,
which you'll hear about in just a few moments,
that our special education division has developed.
These processes and outputs can and should be leveraged
within the DA process and included in the LCAP.
These LEAs already have a jumpstart
in terms of integrated improvement plan
for students with disabilities.
As part of the legal requirement to monitor
local education agencies, LEAs,
the special education supports our districts
to address both compliance and performance areas
through a process that we call
Compliance and Improvement Monitoring, or CIM, C-I-M.
The process places LEAs into tiers of support
and differentiates the support and engagement
based on the need of the LEA.
The CIM is a three-step process that assists LEAs
in answering the following questions.
What's occurring in the district?
Why is this occurring in the district?
And how can we make effective lasting change?
And LEAs engage directly both with CDE and TE providers
through our statewide system of support
and a number of activities such as integrated data analysis,
assessment of infrastructure,
educational partner feedback and focus groups,
root cause analysis, and prioritization.
And all of these activities are with an emphasis
placed on high leverage activities for maximum impact.
The remaining LEAs will also be going through
the CIM process in 2023 this year with the support of CDE.
All of the CIM resources that LEAs use
for improvement planning are available to LEAs
and also are for use in the DA,
or differentiated assistance process as well.
We have carefully thought and built out tools.
Technical assistance and support for LEAs
will be going through CIM in the DA process.
And again, our staff will be working very closely
with differentiated assistance teams and LEAs in the future
to make these resources known and available
so that LEAs can continue to work
throughout the process as well.
In terms of how LEAs are selected for the CIM process,
these are the areas in which each year
the California Department of Education is required
to make what we call annual determinations.
These determinations designate LEAs into the tiers
and determines a level of support.
As you can see here, these five areas
are the areas in which CDE
and our technical assistance providers
provide additional support.
The CIM process, which I spoke a little bit about before here,
again, just sort of a little bit of a visual to the words
in terms of first, again, what is occurring in the district,
that's step one, right?
To figure out what is exactly happening.
Two is investigation, right?
Really sort of drilling down into that root cause analysis
in terms of the why.
And then the third step is the planning process.
And so a comprehensive plan has been developed
for implementation using parts of other plans
that may, or other data, but there is a comprehensive plan
that is developed at the end in which the LEA will use
and utilize as a living document
for continuous improvement efforts.
In years two and three, the process continues.
We know through the lens of continuous improvement
that change takes time.
So steps four include a sort of a step back
and an assessment of actually how the plan is going
and are we meeting those expectations and the goals
in which the LEA set forth.
And so if not, then there is a period of adjustment
to ensure that the LEA is on track.
The implementation updates occur in partnership with CDE as well
to ensure that LEAs are on track to meet their goals.
And then in year three, there is continued implementation.
The LEAs continue to implement the plan,
review any local data that might be relevant,
and then also provide any updates to CDE.
And then also they, again, work with us very closely
to ensure that their plan is aligned tightly
to their goals as well.
All right, so that's just a little bit about an overview
of who we serve in the special education
and how we go about doing our work in terms of monitoring
and support for LEAs.
Wanted to shift our attention to the annual performance report
in and of itself and walk through a few
of the key indicators here today.
We won't walk through every single one,
but you do have them in your packet.
But I will be highlighting several key indicators
throughout the course of this presentation.
The annual performance report is a requirement
of the California Department of Education,
is required of the Office of Special Education Programs.
The State Board of Education must approve this plan
prior to submission to OSEP next month in February.
If you do recall, the targets for this current cycle
that we're in, fiscal year 2020 to 2025,
were approved at the SBE meeting in 2021 last year.
Any of the previous APRs
or state systemic improvement plans can be found
on our website for your reference as well.
I do wanna sort of preface before I jump in,
this is certainly a required activity,
but I think also it's a meaningful activity
for us at the state and really takes shape
and brings sort of a focus area for our work moving forward
as best we can align with our statewide system of support
and our technical assistance and really utilize
and drive these indicators for meaningful change
across the state of California.
So I will jump in here and talk just about
a few of the compliance indicators that you see before you.
These compliance indicators are set
by the federal government, OSEP,
they are either zero or 100.
And so in terms of the, a couple of reminders here
is that indicator 4B is suspension
and expulsion is lag year data.
So that data is reflective of 2020, 2021.
So you see a zero percent here,
that number is likely representative
of distance learning environments
where students were not able to attend school
in the physical sense.
We do expect this number to go up,
hopefully not too much obviously,
as students have returned to classroom.
So next year, this time around,
you will see that number change.
And again, it's because there is a little bit of a lag
year data in that as well.
In terms of, just wanna talk just a little bit about
sort of disproportionate and significant disproportionality.
You know, disproportionality here is a,
really what we call an early warning system.
And so LEAs who have been identified
for disproportionality are required
in a three year process.
The first year is to conduct a root cause analysis.
Second year, they are required
to implement change practices.
And then the third year,
if they are found disproportionate,
they are found to be significantly disproportionate,
which means they must set aside 15%
of their IEDA federal award to develop a plan
to address the needs of the district
and the specific need for the student body in question.
One of the compliance indicators
that I wanted to highlight for you here
was early childhood transition.
I think that this particular indicator,
we saw such a steep decrease last year.
This year, we have seen a noticeable increase.
This could be contributed in continuing ongoing investments
that CDE and the state budget have made
in early childhood and our continued partnership with DDS.
The state budget gave CDE $850,000
and six positions to form a new unit in special education,
specifically to strengthen the transition process
of young children with disabilities
from part C to part B services.
This will allow CDE to work closely with DDS
to encourage a seamless transition and coordination
in our state, regional centers,
and at the local level as well.
In addition, the budget commits $700,000
in federal IDEA funds for the CDE to partner
with the California Department of Developmental Services
to develop parent-friendly resources on transition services,
including the difference between part C and part B services,
options for students after they turn three,
and an overview of the transition processes,
processes and transitions timelines.
We do know that transition for our youngest learners
and our families can often be a scary time.
And we are certainly pleased that this number has increased,
particularly over time and particularly during COVID.
And this is an area that we will continue to focus on
as we know that a smooth and seamless transition
to part B services can set the trajectory
for student success throughout their educational career.
And this will be a continued focus area for us
at the state here as well.
In terms of the performance indicators,
this roadmap here, which you may have seen before,
visualizes how a student is placed and supported
in their least restrictive environment
can have lower instances of discipline.
And this means they are spending more time in the classroom
receiving their instructional minutes,
which can lead to better outcomes
as measured by statewide assessments, graduation rate,
and post-school outcomes.
So we know that a healthy start to education begins at birth.
We know that it starts with high quality early childhood care
and supports and services, with timely assessments,
with appropriate instruction,
and then also provided in the right setting
will lead to those post-school outcomes
that we want to see for all of our students as well.
In terms of our theory of action as well,
again, just sort of a different spin on what I just said,
but again, this combination of, again,
ensuring that we have the right placement for students,
the right supports, coupled with high quality instruction,
oftentimes we know leads to a reduction
in behavior problems, which leads to increased time
in the classroom, increased participation
in the student's learning environment,
which in theory then should translate to graduation
and post-secondary achievement for each student as well.
In terms of the performance indicators that you see here
in front of you as well,
I won't be going through each indicator in the presentation,
all of these indicators, again, within your item.
I will highlight the work that's being done around indicators one,
which is graduation, 4A, suspension, expulsion,
five, educational environments, or LRE,
six, preschool LRE, and 14, just post-school transition.
And again, I think it's important to note that indicators one,
which is graduation, indicator two, dropout,
and 4A are all lag year data,
so these are data pulled from the previous year.
This is the second half of our performance indicators.
Again, won't go through every single one.
I did want to draw out,
and we'll talk a little bit more about it later,
but the post-school outcomes,
we did see some steep decreases last year due to COVID,
and then we're seeing some numbers rebound
as we would like this year as well.
In terms of the performance indicator six,
preschool and least restrictive environment,
this is an indicator that as noted
in last year's presentation to the State Board of Education,
the Office of Special Education Programs
changed the measurement of indicator six
to exclude five-year-old kindergartners.
They had previously been counted in this indicator,
so again, we did expect to see a significant impact
to this indicator this year
after the removal of those students.
This year's data reflects, I think,
sort of a continued refinement to the reported data,
and while it may seem in 2021, 2022
that the indicator 6A decreased by 10%
and 6B increased by 10%.
This does not mean that students
who were in more inclusive settings
were suddenly placed in more restrictive environments.
I think it's important to note there has been a decrease
of over 40,000 students in the population
for this indicator over the past two years,
and again, due to the removal
of the five-year-old kindergartners.
This decrease has been seen and felt across the board
in all educational environments,
so in fact, there were just less students overall
in the indicator and 6B environments as well.
I still don't wanna minimize,
and I think sort of there is a reason, a rationale,
and a condition that has impacted
sort of the numbers that you're seeing today,
but that does not, I think, account for,
or we're not going to sort of lessen our focus
on this area, we know that preschool LRE
is extremely critical, and that while
sort of the calculations have changed
and the landscapes have changed,
that our approach to supporting high-quality
preschool environments will continue
across all settings as well.
And then some of the pre-K investments
that we will be utilizing,
and you'll hear just a little bit more about later as well,
is to address some of the LRE,
preschool LRE that you saw in the last slide.
Children with an IEP or IFSP,
Individualized Family Service Plan,
will be categorically eligible
for California State Preschool.
Along with Stephen Profiter,
we'll talk more about this later in the presentation.
Again, there was a requirement for the set-aside
to reserve at least 10% of students with IEPs,
similar to Head Start, with a phase-in process.
So this year, there will be,
last year was a 5% set-aside,
this year will be a 7.5% set-aside,
and then in starting July 1st of 2024,
there'll be a 10% funded enrollment reserve
for these children, and contractors must serve
those children in those environments as well.
Even if a child does not qualify for an IEP,
the state preschool program will still be an option
for them as well.
And there are also $2,000,001 funds
to incorporate early identification
for learning disabilities
into the state preschool assessment tools,
including a process followed up
by expert evaluators as well.
Indicator five, which is least restrictive environment.
Again, we're talking about the students who are aged five
through aged 20, or in age six through 22,
served inside regular education classrooms.
In indicator five, A and five C are trendy
in the direction CDE would like to see.
Indicator five B is reflective of just,
I think, year-to-year fluctuations.
I think the effort and the emphasis placed on inclusion
or inclusive practices can be felt across the state
in a number of areas.
I would like to highlight the work that's being done
by our partner supporting inclusive practices, or SIP,
S-I-P as we like to call them.
The SIP project supports LEAs to increase access
to general education settings
with research-based evidence practices,
targeted training, and technical assistance
to supporting students with disabilities
in the least restrictive environment.
Currently, the SIP project has 55 LEAs as grantees
as they work closely together as cohorts.
The outcomes for SIP include shifting attitudes
towards inclusion, equity and access,
implementation of inclusive practices,
and utilizing universal design for learning
as a curricular framework,
as well as using evidence-based teaching practices
in terms of moving our key indicators forward as well.
The SIP approach is to assist LEAs
in building strong leadership support for inclusion
and having leaders articulate an inclusion vision clearly
and urgently through formal articulation
and by priority setting as well.
SIP uses several key data sources
to closely monitor the effectiveness of their project
and the work that they do.
Overall, the 55 grantees and those in long
and newer cohorts have shown positive movement
on this indicator.
And then also, SIP was recently tapped
to pilot a project centered on early education at LRE
and two grantees have been selected to this work.
All this to say, the success of SIP has been noted
by the state budget and continues,
and the state continues to invest in the SIP project
and SIP received over $1 million
in the state budget last year as well.
So certainly, the work in LRE, across LRE,
we know takes time.
We're talking about changing mindsets,
we're talking about changing policies,
we're talking about changing practices.
And so, the work of SIP across these 55 grantee areas,
we will continue to scale and certainly support efforts
of inclusion across the state.
The other indicator that I would like to highlight
is indicator 4A, suspension and expulsion.
In terms of the expansion and expulsion here,
the calculation for that is a little bit different
than the dashboard.
So again, we're looking at students with disabilities
who are suspended for greater than 10 days
in a school year, and again, this is lag data as well.
This is the number that was zero.
And again, next year we know this number will increase
by nature of the fact that we are no longer
in a distance learning situation.
In order to address suspension and expulsion
for students with disabilities,
as we know, this is a critical area,
an area of focus for us across the state.
The California Multi-Tiered System of Support, or MTSS,
is a systemic and continuous improvement framework
designed to provide effective technical assistance
for districts and schools to address every student's
academic, behavioral, social, emotional needs
in an inclusive and equitable learning environment
driven by policy and practice,
strong leadership, and family and community engagement.
The California MTSS helps districts and schools
increase attendance, prevent dropouts,
lower disciplinary rates, and improve school climate,
and boost academic performance.
MTSS, or California MTSS, achieves this through coaching,
community practice, and also the MTSS pathway
certification of schools.
And we know that, I think, sort of robust MTSS systems
is a system that, in theory, and certainly a best practice,
should be implemented in every single school setting as well
as it provides the appropriate level of support
for all students in a school setting.
It provides a pro-social and positive environment
for students to thrive and to learn.
Terms of graduation.
Here, again, this indicator is different
than what is reported on the dashboard.
Indicator one is a one-year calculation,
meaning it looks at the percentage of students
who exited special education due to graduation
with a regular high school diploma
out of all students with IEPs that exited special education.
Here, again, we've seen that we are meeting
that indicator as well, and certainly we'll look forward
to increasing this metric as well,
so that all of our students with disabilities
are exiting with a regular high school diploma.
I think, to that end, there have been
several budget investments over the past couple of years
that have sort of spoken to the fact
or acknowledged the fact that there is a need
for certain students with disabilities
to have alternate pathways to get to the diploma,
recognizing that, again, the student body
that we're serving is extremely diverse,
both in sort of demographic but also in need
and recognizing that there are multiple pathways
to get to the same end goal.
And so with that, the alternate pathways to diploma
and some of the work that's being done around that
in the sort of previous and current budget acts
gets to students that have more significant needs
and students that still qualify
for the alternative assessment have a clear pathway
towards achieving a regular high school diploma.
In Decatur XIV, post-secondary outcomes,
again, here, we know that for students with disabilities,
life after high school can look very,
sometimes it's also a very sort of
scary transition process as well,
ensuring that we have students that are
not only graduating with a diploma
but also have a chance to meaningful engage
in college and career or in workforce
is something that certainly is a focus here for the state.
It's also important to note as well
that the Office of Special Education Programs, or OSEP,
has also made this a focus area for the country,
essentially as well, in terms of ensuring
that we have meaningful post-secondary outcomes
and improving our performance
across these indicators as well.
And here, we saw decreases in this number last year,
but we are seeing numbers start to rebound
as we're coming out of the pandemic.
We look forward to seeing these numbers
continue to track positively in years to come as well.
In terms of our state systemic improvement plan,
which is Indicator 17,
which is technically the last indicator,
the ESSEP, as we deem or like to call it,
addresses plans for improving outcomes
for students with disabilities.
The California State Identified Measurable Result,
or we call it the CIMR, all these acronyms,
I know, I'm sorry, is the performance of all of these
with disabilities who took the CASP,
both in ELA and in math.
And then our ESSEP is focused on creating systemic
and sustainable changes,
including the necessary alignment
in statewide accountability and improvement structures,
like the statewide system of support,
to improve outcomes for students with disabilities as well.
So California has made significant progress
in building a statewide system of support
that effectively assist LEAs to design
and implement effective improvement strategies
for students with disabilities.
We know that a comprehensive system of technical assistance
that's available through the statewide system
includes evidence-based practices
to effectively serve students with disabilities.
The statewide system of support seeks to support LEAs'
efforts to implement the improvement strategies
outlined in their LCAPs
and to monitor intended improvement.
California is now in year six
of creating a coordinated and coherent state structure
to ensure LEAs receive the assistance necessary
to address disparities in student outcomes.
California's ESSEP is focused on creating
systemic and sustainable changes,
including necessary alignment in statewide accountability
and improvement structures,
like the statewide system of support, to improve outcomes.
I just wanna go back just really quickly
and talk about one of the areas
that I think will be a key lever in this improvement process
is the IDA Local Control Accountability Plan Addendum.
The 2022 Budget Act included the development
of the IDA Addendum,
which stipulates by July 1st of 2025,
LEAs that have been identified for CDE for improvement
will develop an addendum in conjunction with the LCAP.
This addendum will support inclusive planning.
It's designed to be an inclusive planning process
and will promote cohesion by linking special education
and general education planning,
again, getting to the one system
and closer to the one system
that we all are working towards.
And again, the budget requires the inclusion of parents
of students with disabilities
on district and county LCAP parent advisories committees
as well, ensuring equity of voice for all students.
In terms of sort of what's next for the state
in the system of support here,
we know that sort of everything that we do
is designed to funnel down into the local,
the classroom level as well.
The layering of supports and initiatives and services
is really our goal here,
working both sort of vertically and horizontally,
if you will, with each of the partners
of our educational partners at each level
to really effectively change and work
to improve our outcomes with students with disabilities.
I did want to note, we are also at an exciting time as well.
Our new grant year cycle starts this year,
July 1st of 2023, with our new,
with a new statewide system of support
and special education resource leads.
This grant year cycle will run through 2028.
This time around, the budget has allocated
$12 million annually for this new grant cycle.
The CDE and SBE work diligently to put together
a comprehensive and targeted RFA
to address the areas of highest need at the state
at this current point in time.
And the budget language currently states that
there'll be no more than 10 resource leads.
Three will be, at least three of those leads
will be designated to build local and regional capacity
to support LEAs.
At least one of those leads has to,
support the development and implementation
of high quality IEPs.
One resource lead to develop the capacity
at the LEA level on universal design
for learning framework.
One resource lead to focus on English learners
and how to best support.
And then one resource lead in partnership
with a family support organization
will focus on alternative dispute resolution.
So an exciting time ahead in terms of sort of a new
sort of an additional iteration of this work
and a continuation of this work in general
in terms of how we're supporting and improving outcomes.
We're optimistic about the number,
the quality of applications that we will receive
and along with the work that will continue across the state
and integrate into the statewide system of support.
And now I just wanted to take a brief moment in time
to pause and now transition over to a couple of the,
highlight a couple of the CDE partnerships
that we have strengthened within our own department
and recognizing that the overlaps in the intersections
of students with disabilities, of multilingual students
and our early learners, we can no longer ignore.
We know that there are,
we can no longer ignore, right?
We know that there are areas in which commonly we hold
for our students and so right now we are certainly,
working together collaboratively as a group
in order to shine the spotlight,
elevate the conversation of how we're working together
to address some of the challenges that we face.
As well.
All right, now I'm gonna pass it over to Alicia Moreno-Ramirez
who's the director of the multilingual support division
who will run through just a couple of slides
and highlight the work that both of our divisions are doing
to support duly identified students as well.
Good morning, thank you Heather
and good morning President Darling-Hammond
and members of the board.
My name is Alicia Moreno-Ramirez
and I am the director of the CDE's
multilingual support division.
Today I'll share briefly on some of the key collaboration
across the opportunities for all branch,
particularly highlighting how the multilingual
support division is partnered
with the special education division
and the early education division
to benefit California's diverse children and youth
as well as how we produce together
some of the guidance and resources
also born of that collaboration.
The California Department of Education
multilingual support division or MSD,
the special education or SED
and the early education division or EED
have a history, a long history of collaboration
that's resulted in the development of important policy
and guidance that continues to shape education in our state.
First, the California English Learner Roadmap Policy
or EL Roadmap Policy was developed
through the collaborative process coordinated by the MSD
that included teachers, administrators,
county office of education representatives,
educational nonprofit representatives
and representatives from multiple divisions in the CDE,
including SED and EED.
The English Learner Roadmap Policy was approved
by California State Board of Education in July 12th, 2017.
And as a result of the collaboration with EED,
the EL Roadmap Policy calls out explicit connections
to dual language learners in preschool
and the importance of alignment and articulation
within and across systems.
And due to SED's involvement,
the EL Roadmap also calls attention
to the importance of addressing the needs
of dually identified students across the system.
In addition to providing input
on the policy and guidance document,
the SED also collaborated with the MSD
to develop a three-way crosswalk
between the EL Roadmap principles,
the special education annual performance report indicators
and the local control funding formula priority areas.
This tool allows education leaders
to see the connections between these three areas
as they use this resource for planning,
again, in the best interest of students.
The California Practitioner's Guide
for Educating English Learners with Disabilities
was also developed collaboratively between the SED,
the MSD and through contract with WestEd.
The Practitioner's Guide was developed
to make valuable information
on serving English learners with disabilities
or dually identified students in TK through grade 12,
readily available to busy educators.
These documents continue to guide CDE's work
in supporting English learners
and dually identified students
in preschool through grade 12.
We can pop to the next slide, please.
As part of our ongoing collaboration,
the MSD, SED and EED have continued to engage
to ensure consistent approaches
aligned with the guidance in the EL Roadmap policy
and the Practitioner's Guide
for Educating English Learners with Disabilities.
The goal of this collaboration
is to support local education agencies
to better support and embrace the children
and communities that they serve
and to build upon the assets that these children
and youth bring to California schools.
The MSD and SED collaborate monthly
with the Imperial County Special Education
Local Plan Area or ICSELPA.
At the CDE, ICSELPA collaboration meetings,
the SED, MSD and ICSELPA engage
in collaborative conversations regarding timely topics
such as reclassification,
the alternate English language proficiency assessments
for California or ALT LPAC,
identification of dual language learners
with disabilities in preschool,
English learners with disabilities
placed in dual immersion programs
and other topics related to dually identified students.
Further, the ICSELPA has developed
and presented training modules on the Practitioner's Guide,
co-presented with the MSD and SED directors
on educating dually identified students,
promotes resources to support EL Roadmap implementation
and has provided training for CDE staff
on English learners with disabilities.
The ICSELPA also collaborates
with the 2019 Educator Workforce Investment Grant
or EWIG EL Roadmap Implementation Grantee
called ELRISE or English Learner Roadmap Implementation
for Systemic Excellence
to provide customized professional learning
focused on dually identified students
to ELRISE Anchor County Offices of Education
and participating districts
based upon the needs of local educational agencies.
ICSELPA further provides supports for these counties
to connect with their local SELPAs.
The MSD, SED and the Assessment Administration
and Development Division also meet quarterly
to collaborate on responding to inquiries from the field
that overlap with the work of multiple divisions
such as reclassifying students with disabilities
using the LPAC or the ALT LPAC.
The MSD, SED and EED also continue to collaborate
to create communication pipelines,
co-develop presentations
that reflect the intersectionality of students
and co-present when opportunities like this arise.
For example, the MSD recently developed content
and talking points
for universal pre-kindergarten presentations
and the SED and MSD directors will co-present
at the upcoming California Association
for Bilingual Education Conference.
Region 15 Comprehensive Center
supported the MSD, SED and EED
in cross division collaboration
through a series of facilitating meetings
where we can best see the interconnections
of our work.
These meetings help build the foundation
for ongoing collaboration
between and across the three divisions.
The MSD, SED and EED continue
to build a collaborative relationship
to better support students and the educators
who serve them in assets based and needs responsive ways.
I'll now hand off to,
I believe the Director of Early Education Division,
Stephen Proffiter, is it coming to you, Stephen?
Coming to Stephen.
Thank you, Alicia, we know you're busy.
Thank you, appreciate it.
Wonderful, thank you Heather and Alicia
and good morning.
So to build off a little bit
of what Alicia and Heather have shared,
our divisions have worked closely together
on a number of state initiatives
and efforts to increase access, participation
and supports for children with disabilities
in inclusive early education programs.
A cornerstone of this partnership
is collaboration to support inclusion in UPK
or as we've said earlier,
universal pre-kindergarten planning and implementation.
We've had strong coordination to develop unified
and clear messaging for the field
in our published guidance and our webinars
as well as on addressing any concerns
that come up from the field.
Another area that I wanna highlight
is the huge advancement in inclusion
in the California State Preschool Program
or CSPP as you'll hear me reference later
where we've been working hand in hand
with across divisions to develop guidance for contractors
on how to implement changes related to enrolling
and serving children with disabilities in the CSPP.
The changes will have a huge impact
on access for children with disabilities,
creating more inclusive classrooms
and ensuring that children with disabilities
are educated in the least restrictive environment.
Some of these key changes include
children with disabilities now have categorical eligibility
for the state preschool in addition
to higher priority for enrollment
and by 2425, as you heard Heather mentioned earlier,
our state preschools are required to set aside 10%
of funded enrollment for children with disabilities
and to ensure that children are educated
in the least restrictive environment.
I also want to highlight some key programs
and spaces for collaboration.
Assembly Bill 1808 of 2018 established
the Inclusive Early Education Expansion Program
which you'll hear me refer to later as EAP
administered by the CDE to support early educators
in increasing access to early education programs
like the California State Preschool Program.
Funds support three main areas
including facilities improvements, adaptive equipment
and professional development.
The current year budget also included resources
for state level systems building.
You can refer to page 35 of yesterday's TK item
for more details on this.
Our divisions have worked closely
during the development of the existing grant
and are currently collaborating to expand the program
through an upcoming request for applications process.
Also under AB 1808,
the State Superintendent of Public Instruction
established a cross sector agency work group in April 2019
for the purpose of sharing challenges, barriers
and best practices for inclusion of children with disabilities
and to work towards continuous improvement
of inclusion of these children
in high quality early learning and care programs
in California.
The work group consists of multiple state agencies
and other early childhood constituents.
With technical assistance
from the Early Childhood Technical Assistance Center,
the work group completed a statewide
high quality inclusion indicators assessment
to determine areas of improvement for inclusion
as well as develop a strategic plan.
Currently, the work group is coalescing resources
to support the field and implementing
high quality early learning and care programs.
The three main activities include
creating and disseminating a communications plan
on inclusion, including the development
of a reference guide for inclusion
and resources to address barriers,
reviewing and disseminating existing special education
and inclusion related guidance, regulations and policies
including the development
of a frequently asked questions resource
as well as coalescing best practices, standards
and policy resources,
including a matrix of technical assistance resources
and a review of inclusion assessment tools
in collaboration with Quality Counts California.
To increase collaborative efforts across divisions
within the CDE and to leverage our shared goal
of supporting our youngest learners
with disabilities within inclusive settings,
the CDE established a cross division coordination
on inclusion team in November of 2021.
Currently staff from the early education division,
the special education division
and multilingual support divisions participate on this team
with the intention of adding divisions,
additional divisions as collaborative partners within CDE.
The team is currently revisiting and updating goals
established during the previous year,
which include determining areas of need for the field
and identify resources to support inclusive practices,
determine internal and external
technical assistance needs around inclusion,
including training on the Lanterman Act,
special education legal foundation's best practices
for inclusion, desired results,
access adaptations and accommodation,
universal design for learning
and a program overview from an EAP grantee.
Another goal in this team is to coordinate efforts
between divisions, including determination of ways
that monitoring teams align and how they can collaborate
to best support services to children with disabilities.
While the special education division has been the lead
on collaboration with the department of developmental
services early start program,
it has been clear that the intersection of initiatives
and issues has brought an opportunity for our departments
to deepen their partnership.
The CDE has made efforts to increase support
for children transitioning from part C or early start
to part B special education services,
in addition to children who may become ineligible
for part B services,
but still require early education services.
I'm gonna hand over to Heather to share some background
on the part C to B transition
and the importance of our partnership.
Sorry, now you're in.
All right.
In terms of our partnership with the DDS,
as we like to call them, again, we know that,
and I spoke to a little bit earlier,
the transition to part C to B is one that is a critical time
in a young learner's life.
And so those seamless and coordinated transitions,
again, provide that solid and strong foundation.
And again, as I mentioned previously before,
they're $150,000 plus resources to establish
a early childhood transition or early education unit
within the special education division is being brought to life.
And we should have that unit up and running,
hopefully by mid-February or so as well,
to continue the partnership,
both not only with Steve's division,
but also with the Department of Developmental Services
as well.
Again, the work that we're doing
with both the Department of Developmental Services,
again, working with DDS on specifically developing
both shared resources and parent-friendly resources
that are available on the services that are available
after a child turns three,
and an overview of the transition processes
and timelines as well is a focus area for us.
And then this past summer, both the CDE and the DDS
spent an entire day doing some strategic planning,
which will be the first of many series of meetings
to ensure that both of our agencies are ensuring
that we are both working together
towards a common goal as well,
as well as participation on the Interagency Coordinating Council
for Early Intervention
and our joint partnership with that as well.
And then also hosting and holding
a regional center transition liaison meetings as well.
So again, the importance of partnering with DDS
on sort of the early ed side,
and I would be remiss if I didn't mention
the Department of Rehab on the sort of post-secondary side.
Again, education sort of sits in the middle
of this equation, and it's extremely important
that all of our agencies work in a coordinated manner
to support a student's birth through age 22 as well.
And again, so we are again, working with DDS
collaboratively to again, develop those resources
and work towards our strategic planning,
but a shared goal that our agencies share
is that our early learners have the strongest start possible
in their educational time.
I think with that, we've sort of concluded,
we've had quite a bit of discussion,
I think in terms of just sort of the overview
of the work ahead in terms of sort of currently
where we sit in our annual performance report,
and then the work that we're doing to continue on.
We know that again, while this is federally mandated,
this is the work that we do, and to embed and integrate
and align across all areas and content areas
in multiple contexts, we'll continue to strengthen
our charge and our mission to ensure that all students
are thriving in joyful learning environments as well.
So again, the next step, this concludes this portion
of the sort of presentation, and next steps again
would be pending approval of this item.
The CDE in our division will go ahead and submit
to the Office of Special Education Programs
on February 1st, and typically as typical in years past,
OSAP typically approves those programs or plans
around April of 2023 as well.
So again, we're recommending approval
for the FY 2021 APR and SUP2 submission to OSAP.
Thank you so much for your time, a pleasure to be here,
and happy to answer any questions.
Thank you so much, Heather.
We really appreciate it, and appreciate knowing
what the CDE is doing to advance the goals
as well as what the targets themselves are.
We are going to do some amendments to our next steps.
It turns out that there were some sound issues
on the webcast when we took up items 11
and the waiver consent items.
Although we understand that the closed captioning
was working out of concern for public engagement,
we are going to reopen these items
after we conclude this item.
At this moment, I'm gonna ask for liaison comments
about this item and any quick clarifications.
We'll then take a break before we come back
for full discussion, because it's been a couple of hours
since we started this morning.
So a little bit of adjustments in the flow of the meeting.
And I wanna just give member Yoshimoto-Taryi
an opportunity as our liaison to respond to the item.
If they're clarifying items, we'll take those,
but we'll come back for public comment
and discussion after break.
Member Yoshimoto-Taryi.
Thank you, Board President.
So I'd like to also share my appreciation
not only for today's presentation,
but also for the collaboration
of multiple entities and practitioners throughout the year.
As Director Kalamisi mentioned,
this is a required item for us to review each year,
but it's also about the meaningful continuous improvement
as a state that we want to make
for our students with disabilities.
For a little bit of context, the data in this report,
when it's paired with the data in the school dashboard,
we get a more complete story
on how our students with disabilities are doing,
including the data points that tell us
how preschool students are doing with disabilities,
as well as some insights on how students with disabilities
are doing after high school,
which I think are important to mention.
And it's also important to call out
that the indicator targets in this report
really represent the floor of our expectations as a state,
and we know that there are LEAs and individual schools
within our LEAs that are exceeding
the targets presented here.
And I think it'd be ideal to have practitioners share
in front of the Board at some point
with other practitioners across the state.
So as a final note,
as C.D. highlighted at the top of the presentation,
students with disabilities are students
with intersectional identities.
So we see our students showing up in every student group.
And the meaning of that to me is really
that the success of our students with disabilities
falls on all of our shoulders as a responsibility
and requires the collaboration of multiple divisions
in our systems as we saw today.
So that being said, I look forward to the discussion
on how these data, both in the report
and in the dashboard together,
continue our improvement practices.
Thank you, Board President.
Terrific, thank you.
And I love the idea of us hearing from some practitioners
who've been making progress on some of these things
about how they're doing it.
So we'll keep that in mind for a soon future date.
Are there clarifying questions for Heather
before we take a quick break?
I'm not seeing any hands at this moment.
So we're going to take a 15 minute break, it's 10.21.
Let's come back at about 10.36.
We will then go to public comment.
The public comment slide is posted.
If members of the public want to queue up for comment,
please call the number on that slide
and dial in the participant number.
And then we'll go to public comment.
And dial in the participant access code.
Then we'll take comment, have our board discussion,
and then go back to item 11
to be sure that everyone has had the opportunity to hear.
All right, see you in 15 minutes.
All right, we are back.
And Brooks, could you please call the roll
to establish the quorum?
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Olken.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Here.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Porter.
Here.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Here.
Most present.
All right, so at this point,
we are going to hear any public comment
that may be queued up for item 12.
Is there any public comment?
We do not have any callers in the queue for public comment.
All right, so now we're open for board discussion.
Let us know if you have any comments
or questions on the item.
I am seeing no hands raised.
Do I have a motion to adopt the CDE recommendation?
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
So moved.
Thank you.
Member Lewis, thank you.
We have a second.
I will now call a roll call vote.
Brooks, please call the roll.
President Darling-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Olken.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Yes.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Porter.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Yes.
Motion carries unanimously.
All right.
And now because we did not have a fully functional sound
at the beginning of our meeting this morning,
I am going to report again that in closed session,
the board discussed or took action
on the following legal matters,
Mark S. versus State,
Napa Valley Unified School District versus SBE.
And then we're going to go to item 11,
which is the approval of a charter school number
assigned to a newly established charter school,
Myakamas Charter Middle School.
The CDE recommends that the State Board
assign a charter number to the charter school
identified in attachment one.
And the item will be presented
by Stephanie Farland of the CDE.
Stephanie, please begin.
Thank you.
I'm thrilled you wanted to see me again.
Okay, so item 11, as mentioned,
the State Board of Education is responsible
for assigning a number to each approved charter petition.
This item addresses the assignment
of a charter school number
for Myakamas Charter Middle School, MCMS,
a recently authorized charter school.
A little background on numbering,
California Education Code 47602 states at the SBE
shall assign a number to each charter petition
that it grants pursuant to subdivision J
of section 47605 or section 47605.8
and to each charter notice it receives
based on the chronological order
in which the notice is received.
Each number shall correspond to a single petition
that identifies a charter school
that will operate within the geographic
and site limitations of this part.
Myakamas Charter Middle School
was approved at the State Board
of Education's September 14, 15, 2022 meeting.
The SBE reversed Napa Valley Unified School Districts
and the Napa County Board of Education's denials
of the MCMS petition pursuant to Ed Code 47605 K2E.
At the same meeting, the SBE designated
the Napa County Office of Education
as the oversight agency for MCMS.
MCMS is approved to operate
as a classroom-based charter school
for a five-year term of July 1, 2023
through June 30th, 2028.
The California Department of Education recommends
that the State Board assign charter number 2134 to MCMS.
And that concludes my presentation.
All right, and so the public comments slides
should be displayed so that we can open
the phone line for public comment.
Members of the public wishing to provide comments,
is there somebody putting that slide up?
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on the item may do so by calling the number,
telephone number and using the access code
provided on the slide that will be shown momentarily.
Okay, the slide is up.
Just give them a few seconds
because of the potential lag in the broadcast.
Yeah, we're not seeing the slide yet.
Yeah, it seems like it's trying to come up.
Brooks, I'm not seeing the slide up yet.
So if there's a lag, it's a pretty long lag.
It's on the webcast,
but it isn't showing here on the screen right now.
Okay.
So those who want to call in can see it.
If we're confident that it is on the webcast,
we can open the queue for public comment.
Okay, we currently do not have any callers
in the queue for this item.
Okay, we're sure that the slide is showing.
Yes, we are. Okay.
So be sure, and the sound is being heard.
So with that, given that there's no public comment,
can I get a motion?
Yes, I would like to motion granting a charter number.
And a second?
I'll second it.
Member Rodriguez, thank you.
Brooks, can you call the roll?
President Darling-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Olken.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Yes.
Member Patillo-Brownson.
Member Porter.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Yesha-Mauritari.
Yes.
Motion carries unanimously again.
Thank you.
All right, and now, thank you, Stephanie,
for representing the item,
and we are gonna move on to the waiver consent items.
W1 through W5, and we will now open the phone line
for public comment again.
And is the slide being shown?
Yes, the slide is now up on the webcast.
Okay, so if there are any public comments
on any waiver items one through five,
we encourage you to state your name
and affiliation for the record,
and the waiver item number,
and the district name to which you are speaking.
Please remember to turn down speaker volume
of your computers if you are following the live feed.
The speakers are limited to one minute each.
Are there any public comments?
We do have one caller in the queue.
I will open up the phone line now.
Thank you.
Good morning.
State your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, State Board of Education members.
My name is Cassie Mancini
on behalf of the California School Employees Association.
Thank you so much for reopening the lines on this item.
I just am calling in on item number W04
related to torrents unified school districts labor request.
CSEA very much appreciates the efforts of CDE staff
to work with us to ensure robust stakeholder engagement
on this item, and we're supportive
of the waiver with conditions.
Thank you so much, and you have a great day.
Thank you.
And that concludes public comment for waiver consent items.
All right.
Given that there's no other public comment,
I'll now ask for a motion on waivers one through five.
So moved.
Member Rodriguez, and is there a second?
Second.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry, thank you very much.
And we will now hold a roll call vote.
Brooks, please call the roll.
President Darling-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Member Patillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Motion carries unanimously again.
Thank you.
All right.
And we're gonna move on to item 13,
which is the public comment.
General public comment is invited on any matter
not included on the printed agenda.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling the numbers
shown on the public comment slide.
Is that posted?
It's not where we can see it.
It is being broadcast.
Okay.
And we encourage you to please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Remember to turn down the volume on your computer
if you're following the live feed.
Speakers will be limited to one minute each.
Are there any public comments?
We do not have any callers in the queue
for general public comment.
All right.
So now we're gonna reopen item one
to take action on the preliminary report of actions,
the draft November 2022 meeting minutes,
take up appointments to the advisory commissions
and report on our liaison assignments.
The first is the state board draft preliminary report
of actions minutes for the November 2022 meeting.
While we are waiting for any members of the public
to call in and is the slide posted again on the webcast?
Just double checking.
Yes, it just went up.
Okay, great.
Do I have a motion from a board member
to approve the November 2022 state board of education
draft preliminary report of action meeting minutes?
Aye.
I have a motion from member Roscoe Gonzales.
Is there a second?
Second.
Thank you, member Lewis.
And are there any public comments?
We do have one caller in the queue.
I will open the phone line now.
Okay.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Donahamn
and members of the board.
My name is Nicholas Watson,
speaking on behalf
of the California Charter Schools Association.
He says, they applaud the state board
for its commitment to revisit the verified data list
considered in charter school renewals.
We respectfully urge the board to address verified data
no later than May, 2023 to give charter schools clarity
on which assessments they are allowed to submit
with renewal petitions.
We'd also like to emphasize that we do not believe
that charter schools under the default standard
are required to submit verified data
as part of their renewal process.
We ask the state board to address this issue.
We also ask the board to consider extending
pandemic considerations and verified data.
Currently, the SBA approved verified data
only allow pandemic considerations for 2021,
but this should extend beyond a single school year.
Finally, we recommend the board consider updating
gross norms data submitted for 2023-24 renewals
to account for the ways in which learning loss
has affected student performance.
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes public comment.
Is there any further discussion?
Seeing none.
We have a motion and a second,
so we'll call the roll call vote to music.
It's kind of lovely.
It's certainly the way that we're gonna see
as it snows out today.
Hold on one moment.
Darling Hammond.
Aye.
A member of Escobedo.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Patelo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Member Rosary, yes.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Very unanimously.
Thank you.
So it's been an interesting audio visual meeting.
Our next item is appointments to the ACCS,
the CPAC and IQC,
and I'll ask Vice President Glover-Woods
as Chair of the State Board Screening Committee
to present the committee's recommendations
for appointments to those three bodies.
And we want the public comment slide to go up again
so that after you present your overview
and recommendations,
we can go to the phone line for public comment.
Take it away.
Well, thank you.
I'm happy to report that I will not be singing
the recommendations to you,
but I do want to share that the screening committee
did meet in December and January
to paper screen and interview candidates
for the California Practitioners Advisory Group,
also known as CPAC,
the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, ACCS,
and the Instructional Quality Commission,
and the IQC.
The screening committee included myself,
members Escovedo and Lewis,
and we were also joined by CDE and SBE staff members.
So first to let you know our recommendation for CPAC,
for the California Practitioners Advisory Group,
the screening committee is recommending Samara Polko,
oh, I'm sorry, Polko,
who is a Director of Education
with the California Catholic Conference,
and we are recommending that she serve
as the representative for private school children.
Her appointment is for three year term
starting January 3 through December 31st, 2025.
We also are recommending that Judy Flores,
Superintendent of Shasta County Office of Education,
be appointed Vice Chair of the CPAC group.
For the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools,
the screening committee is recommending Elio Brazil,
Superintendent of Keys Union Elementary School District,
and we recommend that he be appointed
as the commissioner representing district superintendents.
His appointment would be for a two year term,
which would start January 1st, 2023,
and go through December 31st, 2024.
As it relates to the Instructional Quality Commission,
the committee is recommending Cole Vang,
who's the Curriculum Specialist
at the Sacramento County Office of Education.
We recommend that she be appointed
as a commissioner representing teachers,
and that her appointment be for a four year term
starting January 1st, 2023, through December 31st, 2026.
Lastly, we do want to let the Board know
as well as the public that we are currently recruiting
for two positions on the Advisory Commission
on Special Education.
Preference will be given to applicants
who are representatives of charter schools
and parents of students with disabilities.
The deadline to apply will be coming up,
and it will be February 3rd,
and we will bring our recommendations for appointments
to the Advisory Commission on Special Education
to the full Board for vote at the March 2023 meeting.
So on behalf of the screening committee,
I'd like to say congratulations to all of those
who were selected for these various seats
on commissions and advisory groups,
as well as a very large thank you to all who have applied
and took time to interview with us as well.
Thank you.
I want to just be sure that we are able
to open the phone line for public comment
before we turn to our liaisons.
Is the public comment slide up for the webcast?
It has just gone up,
so we should probably give everyone
just a little bit of time here.
Well, we're gonna hear from our liaisons
while the public is queuing up
to call the telephone number and use the access code
provided on the slide that is being shown now.
And while we're waiting for the members of the public
to call in, I want to ask Member Lewis
and then Member Escobedo,
who served on the screening committee
if they have any initial comments.
Member Lewis.
Thank you, President Darlene Hammond.
I would just like to add that we had
a lot of great candidates,
and I think the individuals who were chosen
were also great candidates
and that we expect great things from them
and just appreciative for all who applied
for the various positions.
Terrific, thank you.
Member Escobedo.
I just appreciate SBE staff as well as CDE staff.
I mean, in some cases they were hard decisions,
but we really push our thinking
and we do believe we got the very best
in these committee groups
and really look forward to their unique perspective
in giving us advice and making decisions
on what's best for students.
So really appreciate the thoughtfulness
and the whole organizational structure
to make this occur.
So, and of course, Dr. Glover Woods is amazing
in how she organizes and ensures
that we're walking a very straight path.
That's terrific.
And I want to just appreciate
all of the committee members as well as the staff.
It's an enormous job, takes a lot of care.
And it's also a process of trying to figure out
how to get the diversity of views
and individuals who allow the group
to be greater than the sum of the parts
in making decisions.
So I know there's a lot of thought
that goes into all of that.
We really appreciate all the time and effort
and good thinking that you put into it.
We want to see now if there are any clarifying questions
and then we'll go to public comment if there is any.
Any clarifying questions?
All right, that was very clear.
And is there any public comment?
No, we do not have any callers in the queue
for public comment.
All right, so is there any further discussion
among the Board?
And so I think we're now ready for a motion.
Did I get a motion?
Yes, I move that the Board accept
the recommended appointments from the screening committee.
Thank you, Member Glover-Woods, is there a second?
I second that motion.
Thank you very much, Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
And at that point, I think we just want
to get a roll call vote.
President Darling-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Olken.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Yes.
Member Patilla-Brownson.
Member Porter.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Yoshio Mototari.
Yes.
Motion carries unanimously.
All right, thank you so much, Vice President Glover-Woods.
And we're now going to move to our liaison reports
on activities that are not related
to any items on our January agenda.
And we're going to call on board members
in alphabetical order based on last name.
So, Member Escobedo, you're going to start us off.
Surely.
We'd like to talk about my role with NASB,
which is the National Association
of School Boards of Education.
They empower state board members to leverage their role
in the educational federal ecosystem
to lead for both equity and excellence.
And I would like to have our colleagues,
if they can, attend a annual conference that they have.
And it's typically at a different state each year.
And this year is going to be in California,
specifically in my backyard, San Diego.
So it's going to be on October 25th through the 28th.
I'll send you more details later,
but they typically have experts
to help state board members design systems, right?
That can really expand on the equity and excellence efforts
at each state.
So I'm also part of the planning committee
for this conference.
And we'll be attending,
I'll be representing our state at a webinar
focused on leadership,
on how can state agencies enhance educational leadership
throughout their state as well.
I will be attending a February meeting for CPAC.
And at that meeting,
we'll have a final draft of the state plan for approval.
And we'll have, we'll overview the preliminary results
for our round eight B.
And I think Trustee McQuillan will talk a little bit more
about the meeting that we had in November as well.
And that is my report and looking again forward
to my work as liaison for this year.
And if people have ideas for the program,
it sounds like this is the time
to get those to member Escobedo.
Thank you, thanks for doing that.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes, I'd like to say that member Lewis
will be sharing a bit more
about the instructional quality commission
and member Olken will be talking
about the advisory commission on charter schools.
So I'd like to take my time just to provide the board
with an update regarding the California
Collaborative for Educational Excellence,
also known as CCE.
So there are three areas
that I'd like to share with you very briefly.
The first is in regards to the work CCE has been doing
with the community engagement initiative
and wanted to let the board know that really this past
about a week or so ago, January 11th through the 13th,
the community engagement initiative had its first
or had an in-person cohort,
professional learning network
and it included cohorts one, two and three.
And there were over 44 LEAs that were there.
So schools and school districts,
county office and of education
from that span the state from Shasta
all the way to Imperial County.
So they were all present
at that professional learning network
that took place on January 11th through 13th.
And if you would like more information,
you can definitely go
to the community engagement initiative website
and also encourage you to find out more
about the work that's being done in that area
by visiting the californiaengage.org website as well.
CCE also has a learning acceleration systems grant
and I just like to share with the board that very soon,
the collaborative for learning acceleration
is going to be launching some free online modules
related to areas of math and literacy
and language development.
Also the first annual summit
is going to be held March 11th, 2023.
And so for more information,
you can of course definitely go to the CCE website
or I'm more than happy to share any information
that I may have as well.
There's also going to be a workshop
hosted by Project CLEAR,
which and it'll be a series
of free afterschool virtual workshops
where participants will be able to explore
literacy teaching and learning strategies.
Lastly, just to let everyone know
that the data research learning networks,
which is an opportunity for districts and counties
to transform their data policies and practices
and programs has begun.
There's already an initial cohort.
If interested in the next cohort for the 2023, 2024 year,
please stay posted and keep your eyes open.
More information will be coming out in the spring.
Thank you very much.
I think you might be on mute, Linda.
Member Lewis, it is your turn.
Sorry about that.
Okay, thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
First report I'll give
is for the Instructional Quality Commission.
And as Vice President Gloverwood said,
we both serve as liaisons to this commission.
And so five commissioners have reached the end
of their terms last month
and the student commissioner for the IQC
will term out at the end of this year, this school year.
And at the November meeting, if you recall,
the State Board of Education appointed
four new commissioners and one student commissioner.
And as we just heard today,
we appointed one more commissioner to the IQC.
The next meeting for the Quality Commission
will be next week.
We'll have an orientation for new members at this meeting.
Additional topics at next week's meeting
include the election of the chair, the vice chair,
and the executive committee members,
the appointment of subject matter committee chairs,
assignment of members to the subject matter committees,
the designation of liaisons.
We'll also be reviewing the 2023 IQC goals
and a review of the bylaws.
And if you want information,
the agenda has been posted to the IQC Commission 2023
public meeting notices, agendas, minutes, webcasts page
on the California Department of Education website.
My next report is for the California subject matter
concurrence committee.
Just briefly, if you're not aware of this committee,
their mission states that with an unwavering commitment
to equity, the California subject matter project
seeks to improve student learning
through discipline-specific research-based,
sustained professional learning and leadership programs
for TK through 16 educators.
And you may already know each of the nine projects
in the CSMP network centers on specific subject matter.
And to better serve communities across California,
each project has regional sites
at different colleges and universities,
and they host professional learning programs for educators.
The nine discipline-specific networks
and more than 80 regional sites
serve approximately 25,000 educators
from more than 1,200 school districts on an annual basis.
And the last meeting that we had was on January the 9th,
and I'll just share a summary of that meeting.
And Claudia Martinez from the University of California
Office of the President is the executive director
of the CSMP.
And she gave a presentation regarding the fiscal outlook
that's connected to the CSMP and the work that they do.
And she reported a steady-based funding to continue
and state funding to the UC Office of the President.
And there is federal ESSA funding subcontracted
with the California Department of Education.
Consecutive one-time state appropriations
between the year 2019 and 2023
targeted various areas of professional learning.
And an estimated 25 million in additional funding since 2019
targeted multiple statewide initiatives.
And so I'll just give you a summary of the initiatives
that are being supported by this funding through the CSMP.
The first is expanded services during the pandemic,
including a response to COVID-related learning acceleration.
Second, supporting school districts and county office leaders
through the 21st Century School Leadership Academy partnership.
Third, supporting novice and guest teachers
through the California for Educational Excellence,
CCEE partnership,
and the development of new cross-disciplinary programs
focused on racial justice,
climate change, education, and environmental justice.
And also additional support
for recent state-funded priorities,
namely ethnic studies and computer science.
And I tell you, it was the second meeting
that I'd attended with this group.
And the meetings are very insightful
with all the work that they're doing
to support leaders and educators across California.
And it's just wonderful to hear about the details
of the various initiatives that they have going
and to hear the enthusiasm
and the voices of the various committee members
as they made their reports.
There's a lot of support being provided from this group
to our teachers and administrators.
And the hope is that all of the professional learning
will trickle down to the classrooms across the state
to facilitate positive outcomes for our students.
And if anyone is liking specific information
about what some of these initiatives are,
I can certainly give that.
Was trying to be succinct in my report,
but I do have the information handy
if anyone would like additional information
about any of those initiatives.
Thank you so much.
Member McClellan.
Thank you.
So my report, the first part of it
is the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee
report from there, from the November meeting.
This committee, in addition to guiding the development
of the CTE state plan is responsible
for annually approving the CTE data report
and timeline for meeting
the Career Technical Education Incentive Grant, CTIG,
and the kindergarten through grade 12
strong workforce program data matrix.
At our November 2022 meeting,
the CDE staff presented the following.
We heard a data metrics report
and we're pleased to report the CTE students
continue to outperform all other students
in terms of their graduation rate and the CASP results.
We also heard funding results
from the CTIG round eight requests for proposals.
And then we heard information on the recommended edits
to the CTE state plan made by members
of the September committee meeting.
From the 45 day public comment period
on the statewide plan, we heard the following themes,
aligning across a statewide range of sectors
and interest holders, tackling CTE teacher shortages
and credentialing, addressing challenges
to implementing the high quality WBL, work-based learning,
boosting access to high quality CTE,
support in building out dual enrollment,
supports and services for all student populations,
recognizes student leadership development,
ensuring preparation options for college and careers,
supporting sustainable funding strategies
and improving data collection and use.
Those were the themes that were collected
in the 45 day listening public comment period
for the statewide plan.
Our next meeting is set for February 3rd.
We will hear jobs for the future.
We'll do a presentation on the final draft
of the statewide plan for CTE.
CDE staff will present the preliminary results
from the CTIG round eight B.
And then the chancellor's office
for the community college staff will present results
from the 2022-23 strong workforce grant program.
So that's what we have for the career technical education.
A second point of interest is I've recently been appointed
to serve as a state board of education liaison
to the model curriculum coordinating council.
And this council has the charge of the creation
of the statewide model curriculum,
coordinating council as specified in AB 167.
The council's purpose is to oversee the development
of the four new model curricula,
including the Vietnamese American refugee experience,
the Cambodian genocide among history and cultural studies
as well as the Native American studies.
AB 167 requires the model curricula related
to the Vietnamese American refugees experience,
Cambodian genocide among history and cultural studies
be developed by September 1st, 2024.
The Native American studies curricula
needs to be developed by September 1st, 2025.
We're working with West Ed,
we'll be facilitating the council meetings
which will convene four times per year.
And the first one will be January 31st,
here in a week or so.
And that's all I have to report.
Thank you.
Apologies, President Arnham,
I believe you're still on mute.
I was just saying, it's great to hear
about the model curriculum committee that is launching
and so glad that you're gonna be part of that.
Member Olken, you're up next.
Great, thank you.
And I was just, unfortunately when member McQuillan
was reporting my internet froze twice.
So hopefully if I freeze, I'll be smiling.
In any case, I'm really,
I appreciate this opportunity to share out on a few things.
First, as Vice President Glover-Woods said,
I'm gonna report briefly on the advisory commission
on charter schools.
We had an item that was on the consent calendar,
so I won't go into that.
But we did have the opportunity to thank
four outgoing commissioners who had served the commission
extraordinarily well in the last meeting.
And it was just such an honor to hear
all of the good work that they've done.
So I just wanna give them a thank you here today.
So the four outgoing commissioners were Andrea Faisal,
Gail Garbolino-Mojica, Jared Austin and Wes Siever.
And they were incredible participants
and members of that commission.
The other, I actually have switched liaison assignments
other than that since we last met.
So I'm gonna talk briefly about my new assignment
and then a project that I get to be part of.
So my new liaison assignment is I am the liaison
for environmental literacy, which I'm very excited about.
And I note that President Darling Hammond
has mentioned the importance of this work twice already
in our meetings since we started the year,
both at our first meeting in September
and our meeting in January.
I mean, this one.
First, we were in the midst of a incredible heat storm
and fires across the state in September.
And then now we're all drying out
after weeks of flooding across the state.
And both because of these environmental disasters
and also because our young people are so well equipped
to lead us out of these problems with the environment.
I'm really excited to be able to be a liaison in this role.
As President Darling Hammond noted,
the state has made some significant investments
in environmental literacy
over the last several budget cycles.
And they range from investments in curriculum
and professional development for teachers
in efforts to implement frameworks
that were established a few years back
to greening our school fleets.
And one of the things I think that's particularly
both exciting and challenging about this role
is the way in which we really all have to work together
across agencies and departments
to make a significant impact on the environment.
But I think we recognize that young people growing up
with an understanding of the impact
that they make either intentionally
or unintentionally on the environment
and the ways in which through science education
and research and strong leadership,
they can help be part of the solution
because environmental literacy
is in fact a climate change solution.
I think this is a really exciting assignment.
And I just wanted to note that when yesterday
Nate Watts, who was one of the students
for the US Senate program,
spoke about his desire to work
in environmental sustainability
and to be a leader in those efforts.
I knew I was in the right place
with this new liaison assignment.
So that's the first thing.
And then the second thing I think also equally impactful
and exciting for me is I have the opportunity
to serve on a panel of experts from across the state
related to improving, strengthening
and refining the IEP template that we use in California.
There has been some incredible work already done.
In the last year, there was a work group
of key stakeholders and practitioners
that got us really far along in this work.
And I'm excited to be part of the group
that is looking at ways we can continue
to ensure that IT template drives
student-centered, family-centered,
jargon-free, assets-based, team-oriented,
hopes-driven IEPs for our young people.
It feels like we're on the right track
and it's exciting because we know
all the incredible contributions
that our students with disabilities have to offer.
And I think the process, the IEP process
can both affirm all of those contributions
and help realize them.
So I'm really excited about that work as well.
And I think that's it.
Thank you so much.
That's great, thank you.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
We didn't have a chance to,
the opportunity to meet this past month on assessments,
which is my liaison assignment.
Holidays got in the way, but through my exploration
and the in-depth presentation on item three,
I think of all the teachers throughout the state
just reviewing resources to help their students
demonstrate the standards they've mastered
throughout the academic year and getting ready for that.
I know there's anxiety and preparation,
and I think that sometimes the best way to prepare
is to research and go back into the tools
for teachers at the CDE and take all the resources
they can to prepare.
I'm really interested in, like we mentioned in item three,
how the teachers can review the two sets of educator
resources that are prepared by Smarter Balance
to help them with their higher order thinking skills.
I think that the integrated deeper learning resources,
those instructional resources will help support students
and educators in that full range of higher order
thinking skills that can be measured.
There's a lot of professional learning resources
on the CDE website and the SBAC website to help them
build just that community with their PLC,
their professional learning communities at school
and at the district level and just continue
to provide resources for teachers
to help get their students to meet
that proficient or advanced level.
That's it.
All right.
Member Patilla Brunson.
So there's a couple of items related
to the early learning liaison work.
We had the December California Early Childhood Policy
Council meeting where we heard from the Department of Ed,
folks who have actually provided presentations
yesterday and today.
There was also, I think, really important information
about some misconceptions that are sometimes
out there circulating that we're trying to figure out
how to address and ensure that the misconceptions
don't really take on a life of their own.
There's a section of that agenda around voices
from the field and there was representation
from providers of state preschool classrooms,
teachers who were describing how there was some confusion
among school districts about whether
transitional kindergarten implementation implied
that school districts should ramp down
their state preschool programs.
And as I think was demonstrated by yesterday's presentation
by Sarah Neville-Morgan from the CDE,
the idea of a universal preschool pre-K program
is to have both TK for four-year-olds
as well as ongoing state preschool programs
for three-year-olds on a targeted basis
and that school districts can play an important role
in that, so that I think goes in the list
of important information that we need to ensure
is out there so that the full benefit
of some of these recent early learning investments
can be had for both threes and fours.
There was also a presentation
by the Department of Social Services
on the transition of childcare programs.
This is primarily more in the zero to two
and aftercare spaces and the impact
from recent budget investments on stipends
for reopening providers across a set of age groups,
both for aftercare for kids who are school age
as well as zero to five.
Also in December, the official kickoff
and establishment of the universal preschool
mixed delivery work group began
and we'll actually be having our very first meeting
actually next week.
The focus of this work group is to provide recommendations
on increasing access and updating preschool standards
as was provided in legislation.
Importantly, I think members include many folks
from the mixed delivery service from community-based settings
but also representatives from the county offices of ed
and from TK program leads as well as school districts
which again provide both transitional kindergarten programs
but also provide more than half
of California's state preschool programs already.
The last update is also related to NASB
which I think was covered earlier.
NASB has a early learning work group
which convened in December.
California is a new member
of the early childhood education state network.
It's their fourth cohort of learning states
and we are now alongside North Carolina and DC
covering both how different states are looking
to basically bolster their early learning offerings
for children and families
but also to do the work of coordination
with other state agencies in terms of workforce development,
teacher pipeline, accreditation, curriculum,
and accountability.
And that brings my report to its conclusion.
Thank you.
Terrific.
Exciting to hear about all of the early learning work
that's going on.
Member Porter.
Thank you so much, President Darling-Hammons.
I'm gonna keep my report pretty brief
and just highlight two main areas that I've been working in.
And so the first is that I served as a presenter
at the Association of California School Administrators
Region 14 Conference
alongside Board President Eileen Strauss
and this was a great opportunity
to discuss statewide priorities
and I personally spoke about student concerns
and how to effectively include student voice
and from there ended with an opportunity
to work with these districts superintendents
and administrators to create
their own student advisory councils
and work with me to do so as a way
to accurately get student input on local decisions.
Second, I've been meeting
with various student advisory groups
and I think one of the most impactful conversations
was with San Diego Unified School District students.
I met with them initially to share opportunities
to expand their advocacy on district and statewide level
and then the conversation kind of pivoted
to talking about financial literacy,
mental health and school safety as statewide concerns
and so specifically students were interested
in more resources available to them
learning about taxes and post-secondary education options
and smart investment decisions
and so we had a very important conversation
that I think we continue to have as a board as well
and conversations like these are truly
at the center of my work
and I'm really looking forward to meeting
with more student advisory groups in the upcoming months
and that concludes my report, thank you.
Terrific, I love the fact that we're getting
student voice engaged all over the state,
thank you for doing that.
Next is member Rodriguez.
Good morning, President, members and public.
So I have a few updates,
the CTC for member Olkins benefit
commission on teacher credentialing met in December
and I have a few important and exciting updates.
First, we celebrated the leadership of Chair Tina Sloan
and welcome the new leadership
of Commissioner Marquita Grenoche Shire
who served for years as an ex officio CTC member
representing the CSU in her capacity
as Assistant Vice Chancellor of Educator Prep
and Public Schools Program.
The commission benefited immeasurably
from the leadership of Chair Sloan
and we are all excited to support Chair Grenoche Shire
to take on the reins.
The CTC is completing a multi-year
strategic planning process
just in time for the new chair to lead its implementation.
The plan includes changes in recent years
to the CTC's responsibilities
such as the administration of various grant programs
related to the educator workforce,
expansion of early childhood education prep
and licensure activities and the strengthening
of data gathering and reporting efforts.
The numbers meeting also heard an update
to the classified school employee
teacher credentialing program.
The 2021-22 state budget appropriated $125 million
to be distributed over five years for LEAs
to support classified staff to become teachers.
Round one allocated 14 million to 40 LEAs
to support nearly 3,000 staff to become educators
and the round two RFA deadline closed in December.
Previous funding in 2016 and 2017
supported 2,260 staff to become educators.
If LEAs in your area haven't applied,
tell them to keep their eyes out for future rounds of funding.
Next, a topic near and dear to my heart,
the CTC heard an update from CBE's
National Board and Center Program,
which as you may recall offers teachers a $2,500 subsidy
to obtain their certification
and offers national board certified teachers
$5,000 a year for five years if they teach in a school
serving 55% or more unduplicated students.
In 21-22, the first year of the program,
the subsidy was awarded to, everybody sitting down,
1,712 teachers working in high priority schools,
which is four times the number
that pursued certification prior to the subsidy
and four times the number of BIPOC teachers.
The certification incentive was awarded to 1,945 teachers
also working in high priority schools
and the vast majority of the teachers
are in Los Angeles County.
So kudos to LA, LA County and a shout out
to the rest of the state to step up the subscription
to this incredible program.
A couple of proposed draft literacy programs
and TPEs for early childhood education
and deaf and hard of hearing credentials
are open for public comment.
So since we've been talking about early childhood education,
if you'd like to comment on the standards,
the public comment period is open
and you can visit the CTC website, which is ctc.ca.gov
and you'll find further information
on the page that you land.
And also the commission established a new webpage
dedicated to information and resources
regarding the PK3 ECE specialist instruction credential.
So if you go to the CTC webpage,
you'll find the information and you can go there
because otherwise it's a very long URL.
On this webpage, links are available
to the PK3 ECE specialist construction credential handbook,
authorizations, requirements, standards and teaching.
Next on moving on to going back in the past here,
November 15th, I had the privilege
of attending the Civic Learning Summit in Sacramento,
which was sponsored by Californians for Civic Learning
in partnership with the Power of Democracy
Civic Learning Initiative, Sacramento
and Los Angeles County Office of Ed.
There were about 150 of us in attendance
at the California Museum.
Secretary of State Shirley Weber
delivered a very dynamic opening address
where she compared our democracy to gardening, right?
And when we tend to flowers and they grow,
they grow beautifully, but if we start ignoring the weeds,
they can pop up and within a matter of days, months,
you walk out and your garden's full of weeds.
So we have to tend,
Power of Democracy was her very powerful message.
There were presentations from students,
which was the reason that we were there.
Clovis Tarpey Elementary, the students presented
on their service learning projects.
Edison High School, Black Student Union from Fresno
presented on how they organized
and called out racist images on social media.
A dozen of the students spoke
to the Fresno Unified School Board.
And many of them were speaking publicly for the first time,
but they were prompted by a social media photo
that surfaced of a high school student wearing
or resemble the KKK hood.
And so the Black students at Fresno Unified
say that racial harassment intensified
and especially after racially motivated crimes
as the ones in Buffalo and Orange County.
And students from Anaheim School District
delivered powerful Ted Talks,
where one student talked about having empathy
and understanding and reaching out to refugees.
And another young man talked about food deserts
and how sometimes poor communities have more access
to fast food versus healthy food.
Incredibly powerful Ted Talks.
And it was just, you know, we were all compelled to action.
Lastly, Christine Benson,
the Chair of NASB's Board of Directors,
invited me to co-chair the PEP Committee,
PEP Public Education Position.
And so the NASB, she contacted President Darling Hammond
and then submitted my name to the Board of Directors
and they approved my appointment in December.
And so we'll be currently,
I'll be meeting with the Chair, Lisa Fricke,
and we'll be planning out what'll be happening
for the next meeting, which we'll present in San Diego.
Member Escobedo, you talked about the upcoming NASB meeting.
So thank you, President and members.
That concludes my report.
Thank you so much.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Thank you, Board President.
So I'm happy to report
that I have four new liaison duties.
And I will just briefly touch base on each of those today.
The first one is Civic Learning
and Board Member Rodriguez did such a great job
explaining the event in November
that I'm not gonna reiterate,
other than to say we were just really excited
to see the students.
Their teachers are there, their principals,
their superintendents and their families.
And we were joined by the Chief Justice of California,
Patricia Guerrero,
and she got to meet with each of the students as well.
So that was very exciting.
The second liaison duty
is the Advisory Commission on Special Education.
And as you know, the members of this commission
provide an important service
by making recommendations to us,
to the governor, to the legislature
of research and program development and evaluation.
And what's exciting is with the passage of Senate Bill 291,
the commission will now have two student members
with exceptional needs,
speaking to student voice,
ages 16 to 22 for one year terms.
So that's something to be very proud of.
And the next in-person meeting
is February 15th and 16th in Sacramento.
And my third liaison duty is English learners
along with board member Escobedo.
And as some of you know,
I grew up with my great grandparents
who were English learners.
And so I have a special place in my heart
for the assets, the wisdom and the courage
that comes with the English learner experience.
And the next English learner specialist convening
will be Wednesday, also February 15th in Sacramento.
And so I'll be excited to be there.
And then finally, my fourth liaison duty
is the community schools
that I share with board president Darling Hammond.
And so any day now, please be on the lookout
for the 2022-23 California Community School
Partnership Program or CCSPP for short.
It's a cohort two implementation grant
request for applications.
And the anticipated due date will be in March of this year.
So again, any day now that should post.
And I just wanna highlight that this year's RFA
will require proof of planning,
which is something we learned and found
to be very important to ultimate success
of community schools.
So we encourage all qualifying entities
to apply for this great opportunity.
Thank you, I'll turn it back.
Terrific.
And I'm going to just add a little bit more
on community schools to note that a lot of activity
is upcoming again, as you know,
in terms of implementation and planning grants,
a formative evaluation RFA, which will be going out soon.
So we will have ongoing data from the schools
and the State Transformational Assistance Center
is now up and running.
They are doing all kinds of helpful work
to the field around community schools.
Every Tuesday, they have a learning collective
and people can call in.
There's a time from two to 3.30 where you can call in
and be part of any sharing of information,
asking of questions, getting guidance.
They have developed a set of webinars as well
on culturally relevant family and community engagement,
the role of community school leaders,
building flourishing partnerships.
They're happening on a monthly basis.
All of them are recorded and available in archive
for those who have missed any of them.
And I know that there's a lot of enthusiasm
and activity around both the work that schools are doing
and the work that they would like to do.
And finally, February 3rd is the 50th anniversary of PACE,
Policy Analysis for California Education.
Some of you know about their work.
They are a consortium of universities across the state
that have done research on many things,
including the getting down to facts reports
and a second round of getting down to facts too
that led to a lot of the policy
that we're now implementing
around local control funding formula,
around early childhood education,
around improvements in the work
of the teacher credentialing and support system.
And so they're having their 50th anniversary in Sacramento.
They're doing a conference
and both Mike Kirsten, I will be there virtually.
He will be there, I think in person
to reflect on the way in which that work has informed
the work of the last two administrations
and the state board.
So that'll be interesting for those of you
who want to explore historical roots.
And that concludes my report.
And with that, I think I can hereby adjourn
the January, 2023 State Board of Education meeting
at 11 47 a.m.
And I will look forward to seeing you in March.